PRATIP BANERJI: Sorry
for the delay.
My name is Pratip Banerji.
I am a product manager on the
Google eBooks team, focused on
our syndication efforts.
And I'm going to be joined by
Kevin Landry, who is our tech
lead on the books API team.
We're going to be talking to you
today about "Integrating
to eBooks: APIs to Sell and Read
eBooks for Affiliates,
Retailers and Device Makers."
So high level, what are we
going to cover today?
I'll give you a high-level
overview of what Google eBooks
is, and then I'll dive into
some integration details
around how affiliates, retailers
and devices use our
Books APIs to integrate
with us.
I'll hand it off to Kevin,
who'll walk through some of
the APIs and go into a little
bit of detail around what they
are and how they work.
And he'll also walk through
eBook integration.
And he'll hand it back to me,
and I'll walk through an
affiliate example integration.
So let me start off with
a quick video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-The book business hasn't
changed very much in
the past 500 years.
Someone writes a book.
Someone publishes it.
And you buy it and carry it
around until you're done
reading it.
Then, if you're a book lover,
you repeat this process for
lots and lots and
lots of books.
But in the past ten years, a
very big change has happened.
Books have gone digital.
Today there are all kinds of
eBook standards, each with
their own dedicated e-reader
and their specific place to
buy eBooks.
And all lacking one
thing: choice.
The idea behind Google eBooks
is to truly set your reading
free from all these
limitations.
Google eBooks stores your
library safely in the digital
cloud, which means you get to
shop for all your favorite
books wherever you want, and
read them wherever you go,
using pretty much any device
with an internet connection.
Let's say you wake up one
morning and decide to read The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo.
You might begin the story at
home, on your laptop, over
coffee and a pastry.
You'll really be getting hooked
on your tablet on the
train to work.
And by noon, you'll be racing
through the chapters on your
smartphone, when you head
out to grab some lunch.
Now imagine if you're carrying
around not just one book, but
a lot of them.
Like maybe a couple
million of them.
With Google eBooks, syncing
all your books with your
devices isn't just simple,
it's automatic.
You can take a break in the
park with some Stevenson.
Reference your favorite French
cookbook at the supermarket.
Get lost with Grisham on
the crosstown bus trip.
Whenever you open one of your
books, we'll pick up right
where you left off.
With millions of books to
choose from, in every
imaginable category, finding
what you want to read on
Google eBooks is easy.
You can check out The New York
Times bestseller list. Browse
the Google eBooks store, and
find recommended titles or
free eBooks.
Discover up-and-coming
authors.
Or buy eBooks from the growing
number of independent
booksellers and retail
partners.
Google eBooks is all
about choice.
From what you want to read,
where you want to shop, to how
you want to read.
That's all your books
in one place.
No matter where you go.
That's truly reading unbound.
Start exploring Google eBooks
at books.google.com/ebooks.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So that gives you a little bit
of an idea of what Google
eBooks is about.
But just to add to that, our
goal was to create an open,
cloud-based e-commerce platform
that allows for the
browsing, buying, storing
and reading of eBooks.
We launched the service in
December of last year.
And one of our guiding
principles was we not only
wanted to allow our users access
to eBooks, we wanted to
also support an open ecosystem
that lets our partners play
and make money in the
digital eBook world.
So some interesting stats about
our service: We have
over 5,000 publishers that
have made their titles
available as Google eBooks.
And over 3 million Google eBooks
are available, of which
hundreds of thousands are
available for sale.
And we have over 200 retail
partners in the US that are
selling Google eBooks today.
So let's dive into some detail
around how these partners
integrate with us.
So first, who are these
different partners?
The first set of partners
are affiliates.
Affiliates are web-based
publishers that want to make
money by referring their users
to Google eBooks and then
getting paid a commission when
that user buys the eBook.
I expect most people here are
probably interested in this
affiliate program since that
is the easiest path to
integrate with us.
The second type of partner we
work with are retailers.
Retailers are partners that want
to tightly integrate with
Google eBooks and own the
customer experience.
So they are taking Google eBooks
and selling them to
their customers.
This is a lot more integration
work, but the end result is
that they maintain a customer
relationship.
And the third type of partner
that we're talking about are
device manufacturers.
Device manufacturers are
typically hardware vendors
that are looking for a way to
provide their users access to
a rich set of content
from Google eBooks.
To enable these partners,
we've created a set of
services and APIs.
We use GAN, the Google Affiliate
Network, to track
when an affiliate sends us a
user and pay out commission.
We use all sorts of user
authentication protocols, like
OAuth, to ensure that our users
have a mechanism to
authorize themselves with these
third party services.
And we use Books APIs to allow
our partners to search within
our catalog, as well as allowing
our users access to
the library within the cloud.
In addition to these services
and APIs that we've created,
we rely on third party
industry standards.
We use ONIX for sending catalog
information to our
retailer partners.
We use EPUB and PDFs
for transmitting
files to hardware devices.
And we use EditX for
communicating transactional
information between us and
our retail partners.
So with that, let's dive into
some examples of how each of
these partners integrates
with us.
I'll start with affiliates.
So the example here is a
financial blog run by Joe.
What Joe wants to do is, he
wants to provide advice to his
users on finances.
And every once in a while when
he's providing advice, he
refers them to a book.
And what he'd like to do when
he refers them to a book and
this user goes and buys a book,
he'd like to make a
commission on that purchase.
So what Joe does is he first
sets up an account with the
Google Affiliate Network.
And with that account setup,
he gets access to a GAN
product feed.
And what this GAN product feed
gives him is a list of all the
books that he can refer
to Google eBooks.
If he doesn't want to use the
GAN product feed, because it
is a big file that he has to
parse, he can use our Books
APIs to specifically query
Google Books and find out if
books are available for sale.
And if those books are available
for sale, then find
out what the referring link
for that book should be.
So once Joe has this set up,
users can come to his site,
browse his site, and when they
find a book that they're
interested in buying, they click
on the link for that
book, a buy link on Joe's
Financial Blog.
And what that link takes them
to is the Google Affiliate
Network, who tracks that this
referral was taken in, and
refers them on to the
Google eBookstore.
Now this happens completely
opaquely to the user.
The user doesn't know they're
going through GAN.
And they can end up either at
the front page of the Google
eBookstore, or they can end up
at a specific "about the book"
page that is tailored for the
book that Joe is recommending.
So the user can browse the
site at that point, do
searches, buy the book that they
got referred to, or buy
another recommended book.
And when they find a book they
want to purchase, they go
through the standard Google
Checkout process, at which
point the book is pushed
into the user's
library in the cloud.
In parallel after that occurs,
Google eBooks sends a message
to the Google Affiliate Network
saying that that
referral that came in
resulted in a sale.
And then on a monthly basis, the
Google Affiliate Network
pays out a commission to Joe's
Financial Blog based on the
sales that they helped
generate.
So in summary, what Joe's been
able to do is take this blog
and monetize it, by referring
his customers to Google eBooks
to buy books that he's
recommending.
The integration is fairly
straightforward.
It's probably a couple of days
of effort, and maybe a couple
of days of waiting for all the
approvals to go through.
But it's not a whole lot of
engineering effort, it's not a
whole lot of time.
The second type of integration
I want to walk through is a
retailer integration.
The example here is you have a
print retailer who wants to
add eBooks to the set of
products that they're selling.
So the example at the bookstore
I made up, called
Fancy Books.
They sell all sorts of fancy
books and the first thing that
they do is get an ONIX feed
from Google eBooks.
This ONIX feed is a very
detailed catalog of all the
books that are available for
sale and a lot of information
about those books.
So metadata, publisher
information, wholesale price,
discount codes, et
cetera et cetera.
And what it lets Fancy Books do
is incorporate the entire
Google eBook catalog into
their overall catalog.
So they can provide their users
the ability to search
across both sets of data.
So that what happens is, if the
user's looking for a book
on wine, they can find print
books, they can find eBooks,
and they can find books that are
available in both formats.
So it's one unified
search mechanism.
The next thing that Fancy
Books can do is enable a
previewing mechanism.
Using our Books API, Fancy
Books can give users the
option of clicking on a little
Google preview button and
reading a small sample of the
book to figure out if it's
really of interest to them and
if it's something that they
actually want to buy.
Next thing that Fancy
Books does is a
transaction with the user.
In this case, because it's a
retailer, the retailer is
responsible for doing the
transaction, for accepting the
credit card, processing
tax, all that stuff.
And when that transaction is
complete, they send a message
to Google eBooks using EditX
saying that somebody actually
bought a book.
And then the user uses OAuth
to link their Fancy Books
account with their Google
eBooks account.
And at that point, the book is
pushed onto the user's Google
eBooks shelf, and the user has
the option of reading it on
any device that's Google
eBooks-compatible.
And the last thing Fancy Books
can do is, after the user's
bought the book, using our
APIs, they can provide a
mechanism for reading
that book on
the Fancy Books website.
And they can actually access all
the books that user's made
available on their library
through that interface.
So in summary, with this
retailer integration, they do
control the end-to-end customer
experience, the
retailer does, but it
is a lot more work.
The amount of work required
is on the order of months,
whereas an affiliate
integration is on
the order of days.
The last type of integration I
want to walk through is the
device integration.
So this is a hardware
manufacturer that wants to
give their users access
to Google eBooks.
So there are two parallel tracks
of integration that we
have to think about when we're
thinking about a device
integration.
The first is a buying
experience, and the second is
a reading experience.
On the buying side, the first
thing that the user does is
accesses a mobile web
store using HTTP.
They can browse, they can
search, they can find books
that they're interested in.
And once they find a book they'd
like to buy, they go
through the standard checkout
process, using HTTPS.
And when that book is bought,
it's pushed down to the user's
Google library.
In parallel, to provide reading,
what the device does
is it gives a user the option
of authenticating, either
using client login or OAuth,
with the Google eBooks service
through the device.
And then using the Books API,
the device is able to download
a list of all the contents
of that user's library.
I mean information about the
books that are in their
library, things like reading
position are provided.
And then when the user wants to
read a book, and it's not
already on the device, it
can be downloaded in
EPUB and PDF format.
And all this happens
behind the scenes.
The user doesn't see it.
The device actually manages
that interaction.
So with that I wanted to hand
it off to Kevin, who's going
to walk through some detail
around these APIs.
KEVIN LANDRY: All right,
thanks a lot, Pratip.
So when we talk about the APIs,
let's talk about what
data we're going to be using.
So one is volume information.
That's basically the
book content.
The metadata, title, author.
Typical stuff, you know.
User content.
So that's what we store
for the user.
The user can go on our site.
They can create a review.
They can rate a book.
They can also create
bookshelves.
So we have the My library
bookshelf.
So it's My Google eBooks,
Purchased, Reviewed, Recently
viewed, all those are
bookshelves and you can query
those on behalf of the user.
The next item is order
information.
So again, if you're doing that
deep type of integration with
us, you can do order type
of information.
That's the EditX.
And then output format.
So output format is
JSON, XML, and the
new industry standards.
So we have the EditX and ONIX
feed that Pratip mentioned.
And then also book content.
So book content, obviously
they're going to read the
book, so we do it
in PDF and EPUB.
And then also we have
an embedded viewer.
We'll get to the embedded
viewer.
It's actually pretty cool.
So you can actually put the
viewer right on your web page
for certain eBooks.
So API technology.
So we announced today the
new Books Labs API.
So it's a JSON response.
The code site is there, so you
can go there and read up about
the documentation for
how to call the API.
And we also have the URL there,
so that would be the
actual prefix you're going to
use to actually call the API.
And the authentication, so we
do support OAuth 2.0, and
OAuth 1.0, so you can use OAuth
Playground to actually
go through and mimic calls
on behalf of the user.
And we mentioned the industry
standard API, so we have the
EditX feed and the ONIX feed.
So EditX is for inquiries,
orders.
And the ONIX feed is for,
again, product type of
metadata information.
And then book content.
So we talked about the EPUB,
PDF, and it is using the Adobe
Digital Editions talking
encryption.
And more.
So here is the embedded viewer
API, which is pretty cool.
So you can actually embed
the book content.
If you look there for the actual
JavaScript, there's an
ISBN tag there.
So you can actually put in an
ISBN, put that little viewer
right on your web page,
and people can
actually view that book.
So what kind of integration do
we have at the eBook level?
What are some of the
calls we're going
to actually be making?
So on behalf of the user, we
have these calls here.
So we have the reading
operation, so they typically
read either on the HTML side,
the JavaScript side, they're
using the JavaScript reader.
And then also, they can also
read on the devices.
So we have the Android, IOS,
and e-Ink devices that
actually read the
PDFs or EPUB.
And then the third type of
integration there is the My
library researching.
So they can actually talk to
our APIs to grab the user's
library, or actually make
queries directly to us for
book content.
So they can query off of text,
they can query off of the
title, the author, and we can
go through some of those.
What do you need to actually
talk to the Google Books API?
You need a developer geek.
It's similar to the
other Google APIs.
So you can go to the API
console, you can actually
register there and just say, I
want to use this API, and it
gives you a developer key.
That developer key you're
actually passing in as the key
parameter on each
of the requests.
You're going to make the
request, and we have two types
of feeds here.
So we have the volume
information feed.
So the volume information
feed doesn't require
authentication.
And that's where you'd be doing
the querying on metadata.
So give me the books that
are about Mark Twain.
Give me the books
about whatever.
And then we also have
the bookshelf query.
So this is where you would be
querying the user content.
This does require
authentication.
This is where you're going to
be doing the OAuth on behalf
of the user.
And I'll do a demo here.
So this is a Chrome extension.
How many of you guys have done
a Chrome extension before?
A couple.
OK.
So I'll show you how easy it is
to do a Chrome extension.
So the first thing you need is
there's a metadata description
file, which you actually
create.
With XML it's pretty easy.
Then you actually have the
background page, and the
background page stores
the content for what
you're going to do.
So it stores the content
across tabs.
You have the content script.
The content script actually runs
within each page that you
have. So when you load up a web
page, the content script's
going to run.
And then you have the popups.
So the popup gets run, in
this case, when you
click on the icon.
You click on the icon, the popup
will run, and go ahead
and make the necessary queries
to the background page.
What we're doing in this
particular example is we're
actually going to be using that
query there, and we're
actually passing in an ISBN.
So we're going to look for the
ISBNs for a web page, group
them all up, make sure they're
unique, pass them each to a
query to our API, and we're
going to return results and
then show it on the page.
So let's get to the
example here.
So I am on the San Francisco
Public Library.
And let's click on new titles.
Let's try that again.
Ah, there we go.
And new fiction titles.
And let's click on
one of these.
And our little extension's
running up here.
So boom, it popped
up a number.
What that says is there's
actually two
ISBNs on this page.
If you actually scroll down at
the bottom, they're both about
the same book, But there's
actually two different
variants of ISBNs.
There's a 10-digit and
a 13-digit variant.
So you actually click
on this here.
What you see is, we actually
make the query to our servers,
pass in the ISBNs.
We understand that there's
actually two ISBNs we pass in,
they actually come back with the
same result so we actually
only show one result here.
We can actually click on buy now
if you wanted to buy now.
And you can log in and
actually purchase it.
Or if you actually click on the
title or in this case the
image, you can actually see the
metadata about the book.
So this is our about the book
page where we have reviews,
related books, all
that good stuff.
So let's see what exactly
this extension is doing.
So let's look at the background
page first. So it
is an extension.
Need developer mode.
Let's see if I can actually
change some of these things so
you can actually see it.
Can you guys see that?
Yes?
No?
A little, kind of?
OK.
So we're actually
doing it here.
So the first thing we have
up here is the book tabs.
That's actually our object where
we actually store the
ISBNs for tabs.
So every single tab, we
actually have two
properties in there.
One is ISBN and one is
actually the results.
So if you've already done the
results for that page, we
could just get the results
cache back.
Otherwise you have the list of
ISBNs to actually query.
This is actually our
main function.
It actually gets called
down below
within some of the listeners.
What this method does, is it
actually sends the request--
you'll see right here, there's
actually a send request call--
it actually sends the request
to the actual content page.
The content page has that
listener that's running from
the content script.
So we send the request
to the page.
The page goes through, scrapes,
gets all the ISBNs,
sends it back here at this
point, and then we
actually store it.
We don't actually make
the query until
it gets on the popup.
And then here you see actually
the listeners.
So these are listeners
that we're actually
doing for each tab.
So when a tab gets opened, the
listener gets called, calls
back up to the first method,
that then calls into the
content script.
And we can find the content
script by looking at our
lovely developer tools.
So as I mentioned, it gets
loaded on each page, and you
can actually find it there.
It actually will say Chrome
extension there for each of
the extensions.
In this case, the first thing
we're doing up here is routing
the listener.
So this is a listener where the
background page actually
calls into it.
And then what the listener then
does, is it calls findBook.
And you'll see within findBook,
there's a series of
regular expressions because it
actually ends up being--
there's different formatting
ways that pages can actually
display an ISBN.
So we actually go through each
of the regular expressions,
pull out the ISBNs, and then
that's what we actually send
back to the background page.
And then on the popup here--
So the popup has-- let's
go down here--
so it actually will go
through initially
and do a search page.
So the search page will
actually call
the background page--
you see right here, get
background page--
get the information about
the current tab.
And here it actually decides if
there's ISBNs or if there's
actually results.
It's just ISBNs.
Then the next thing we actually
do is go back here
and we get the text
for the ISBN.
So what you see here
is the actual query
that's being executed.
So it's googleapis.com/b
ooks/v1/volumes, passing in
that key parameter that I
mentioned before, and then the
query is ISBN, colon, and
then an actual ISBN.
And then what happens is you
take the response text-- it's
a simple XHR request--
take the response text, pass
it to your JSON parser, and
then actually passes
it into a method.
And then the method, actually
in this case, simply goes
through and pulls out each of
the identifiers, or each of
the pieces of information
we need.
You'll see here there's
actually a book ID.
The JSON object is pretty
self-explanatory.
There's an ID for the book.
There's authors.
There's title.
And we'll get to some of that.
So here's an example.
This is pretty much what will
happen in the popup.
So we have the get, and we're
actually passing in the key,
and there's the ISBN.
This is a little bit easier
to read here.
And then also, each of the
responses, so as I mentioned
there's a book ID.
There's also the thumbnail
information that we pull out,
the volume information, and
we'll get into what's exactly
in that volume information.
The title, as an example.
So here's an actual JSON object
that can be returned
for a volume query.
So it actually has a bunch
of identifiers in
there for the book.
And the next big section in
there is the volume info.
So that's the general, again,
volume metadata information we
have. User information, if you
authenticate you will get the
user information as well.
This is what the user
has stored with us.
Sale information, again, if
there's information relative
to the price, we have
that as well.
And access info, if there's
access information about the
book relative to the country
that you're in.
So volume information, so the
standard stuff again,
interesting thing here is that
types, so we do have multiple
types in there.
So ISBN, 10 and 13 depending on
what the exact volume is.
Average rating, content
version.
Content version's interesting
if you're actually going to
start doing the device
integration.
You're actually going to want
to talk to us because the
content versioning comes
into play there.
And user information.
So we have the review, the page
position-- so that's the
position where the user
last left off--
as well as if they purchased
it or not.
Sale information.
So this is sale information
for the book.
So currently only in the US,
so it'll have the US dollar
price, list price,
and the amount.
And actually the buy link so you
can actually put that link
on your page.
And access information, so
that tells you for the
country-- again we're only
in the US right now--
for the EPUB, PDF downloads, as
well as if it's a sample or
otherwise if it's embeddable,
public domain.
And the volume query.
So the volume query supports
multiple different types of
parameters here.
So you see the query, that's
probably the biggest one that
people will be using.
There's filtering, language
restrict.
And bookshelf.
So the URL at the top there is
actually our URL if you would
hit our book site, you would
actually have that URL there.
That AS collection ID is
actually the bookshelf ID.
So you would replace that into
your bookshelf's URL query.
And you can use OAuth playground
right now to go
through and actually execute
these queries.
EBook partner integration.
So this a little
bit different.
So we talked about the ONIX
feed and the EditX feed.
So the book catalog is through
the ONIX feed, and then the
website, the user can buy on the
website and actually do an
EditX transactions with us,
which will actually be the
order information.
And then of course they can
access the APIs for doing
searches against our
repository or
the user's My library.
Here's an example of
the ONIX catalog.
So again, ONIX and actually
EditX have a section here that
you can customize.
So we've actually customized
some of these parameters here,
some of them are in red.
And you're going to want to talk
to us at this level when
you start integraiton.
Here's EditX again, there's some
customizable fields in
here, with the order
information.
And here's an example of
the actual structure
of the XML for EditX.
And with that, I'll hand
it back over to Pratip.
PRATIP BANERJI: Thanks, Kevin.
So what I want to do is quickly
walk through an
example of an affiliate that's
integrated with us.
The example I'm going to walk
through is a social reading
site called Goodreads.
Have people here used
Goodreads before?
Is there anyone that's
familiar with them?
That's great, so a few people.
It's a site that you can go to
to see what your friends are
reading, review books
or recommend books.
It's really just a social
reading destination.
So what I want to walk through
is a user perspective.
When a user comes to Goodreads
and they browse this site, how
do they actually get referred
to Google, and
how does that work?
So the first step is a user
comes, they're on the
Goodreads site, they browse
it, they learn about what
their friends are reading.
And at some point, they
find a book that
they're interested in.
And they click on the
icon for the book.
And this takes them to a
Goodreads page that has
information about the book.
So it's got a description.
It's got ratings.
All sorts of useful information
for the user.
If you look over there on the
left, there's a little Google
Preview button.
And using our APIs, what
Goodreads has done is
implemented the ability for a
user to come and actually read
a subset of the book by clicking
on that button.
So what that does when the
user clicks on it is a
viewport opens up that lets them
read a couple of percent
of the book, depending on what
the publisher allows.
They can get hooked
on the book.
They can figure out if
they like it or not.
And if they get to the point
where they're like, you know,
I do want to buy this book,
what Goodreads has done is
implemented a little buy a copy
button that has, among
other providers, a Google
eBook logo.
Or I guess text in this case.
If the user clicks on this,
if you think back to the
affiliate integration
architecture that I laid out,
that user is directed to the
Google Affiliate Network, who
tracks that a referral came in
from Goodreads, and then GAN
automatically redirects them
to the Google eBookstore.
And once they get to the Google
eBookstore, the user
has the option of reading more
about the book, seeing how
much the book costs, which is
obviously important, and if
they want to buy the
book, they click
on the buy now button.
And then they go through
the standard
Google Checkout process.
They buy the book.
The book is pushed into
the user's library.
And then after that happens,
Google eBooks tells GAN that
this user that Goodreads sent
in actually bought the book,
and then there's a
periodic payment
that goes to Goodreads.
So what Goodreads has done is
they've taken a social reading
destination that they've created
and they found a way
to monetize it, by making money
whenever one of their
recommended books gets purchased
as a Google eBook.
So with that, I want to close
with a few thoughts.
The first is that Google eBooks
offers a brought set of
APIs and services that not only
enable our users to read
books, but allow partners to
participate in the digital
eBook ecosystem.
So what does participate mean?
For affiliates, it means they
can earn money by referring
customers to Google eBooks.
For retailers, it means they
can make money by selling
Google eBooks to their
customers.
And for devices, it means that
they can add value to their
device by integrating with
Google eBooks and giving their
users access to rich content.
If you'd like to learn more
about APIs, more detail than
Kevin's gone through, please
go to our code site,
code.google.com/apis/books,
and currently the Google
eBooks affiliate program
is still in a
invitation-only beta.
But it's going to be
going live soon.
And if you'd like to be notified
when it goes live,
you can visit that short
link, goo.gl/2fm7q.
And you can sign up to
be notified there.
And last but not least, one of
our retailer partners is
demoing their integration in
the Google I/O Sandbox.
Powell's, which is a retailer in
Portland, has done a great
job integrating with us.
They'd love to show you
what they've done.
They'd love to talk to you
about their experience.
If you'd like to hear more about
that, please stop by
their booth in the Google
I/O Sandbox.
So that's what I had.
Please feel free to provide
feedback using that short
link, or if you've got
the Android app.
And we have a few minutes, so
Kevin and I are happy to take
any questions that
you have as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRATIP BANERJI: Sure.
Can you come up to the
microphone when you ask your
question, just so they
can capture it?
So for the affiliate, the buyer
who came to the Google
bookstore, does the affiliate
get credit for that particular
book, or for any other book that
buyers end up buying, or
is there a duration for which
that's effective and so on?
PRATIP BANERJI: So as long as
they buy the book in the
session that directed them to
the Google eBookstore, then
they get credit.
So what happens is when they
come in from GAN, there's an
affiliate ID that's attached to
the Google eBook URL that
they're going to.
So within Google eBooks, as long
as that ID is in there,
we track where they
came in from.
Now if they leave the site, and
then they come back the
next day, and they just go to
the bookstore directly, then
the affiliate won't
get that credit.
So if they keep the window
open, how long
that's taking now?
PRATIP BANERJI: You know, I
don't know the duration of how
long that session stays open.
I don't imagine that there's a
limit that's unreasonable.
But I'm not completely sure.
But I'm happy to find out for
you if you come up afterwards.
I can find out what the duration
of time would be.
Also, you mostly talk
about the API for
affiliates and retailers.
Are there API available for
if you want to enhance the
reading experience itself.
For instance, are there already
annotation service
available for reading?
And how is that?
PRATIP BANERJI: So we don't
have annotation services.
But we do have a broad
set of services
available through our APIs.
I don't know, Kevin, if you want
to list off the kind of
things that we do have.
KEVIN LANDRY: We have the
services for getting the
metadata in terms of the volume
information, as well as
the user's bookshelf.
We don't have anything for
modifying or augmenting the
content at this point.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So let's say if I develop a
reader for reading eBooks in
Google books, and obviously I
want to store the book in my
library, but also as well as
any notes, annotation I may
have on the book in
my library also.
And that should be
cloud-synced,
not on my local e-reader.
PRATIP BANERJI: Yeah.
That is a good idea.
We're evaluating a
lot of potential
places to grow the product.
Thanks.
Two slightly separate
questions.
The first, what limits do you
have on the use of the API for
number of books that can appear
on a single bookshelf,
and number of full
text searches
against that bookshelf.
Full disclosure, I work as a
librarian at a university.
We're interested in very
large numbers.
KEVIN LANDRY: OK.
So, in terms of the actual QPS,
the QPS number is you
actually sign up, when you sign
up on the code site, you
actually see the QPS.
And you can actually
request more.
So there's actually a process
to actually request more.
We don't have anything
specific in terms of
differentiating between, say, a
text query or querying on a
user's bookshelf.
And right now, I don't believe
there's any limitation on how
many books a user can have in
their bookshelf as well.
OK.
That's one thing
I like to hear.
The second thing is, just noting
the video at the start
said that people buy
a book, and then
they buy another book.
It left out the part where
people borrow books, or lend
their books, after they're
finished reading it, to
somebody else.
So that raises a question, given
Kindle and Nook having
very limited, artificial
loan programs,
but at least something.
What sort of plans do you have
for implementing those sorts
of features?
PRATIP BANERJI: We don't have
that feature right now.
Right.
OK.
Do you have any plans?
PRATIP BANERJI: Um--
Can't talk.
That's OK.
I understand.
All right.
Any plan to get it
out of the US?
PRATIP BANERJI: We do
have plans to launch
internationally this year.
When?
PRATIP BANERJI: Over the
course of this year.
OK.
Kind of a techie question.
I notice that you weren't really
displaying Atom and
that you were defaulting
to JSON.
Is that--
KEVIN LANDRY: That's
on purpose.
That's on purpose?
KEVIN LANDRY: Yeah.
And the API is still
GData-ish?
KEVIN LANDRY: No.
So it is more of a REST API with
an actual JSON response.
So how I went through that
object, you're actually
getting a list of books back.
And each of those book objects
have that volume information,
write user information.
So it's all through the path.
KEVIN LANDRY: Yeah.
It's very much object-oriented
in terms of the structure.
GData kind of forces you into
a certain structure, as
opposed to just having
objects.
So how does that work
with the OAuth now?
I didn't see an OAuth
integration.
KEVIN LANDRY: Yeah.
I didn't do an example
of OAuth.
But you can actually go to
the OAuth Playground.
So if you authenticate, and
then you go through the
permissions, and you actually
paste in the URL with your
bookshelf, pass in your key as
a parameter, you can actually
execute it right there.
It'll actually give
you the result.
1.0, 2.0, signed?
Sorry.
KEVIN LANDRY: Yes,
yes, and yes.
OK, thank you.
I'm curious about the content
providers and the content that
Google eBooks offers.
I was surprised in the book--
what was the example
book, Goodreads or
whatever it's called--
that I assumed when you had a
book, when you pulled it down
that content was either being
published by Amazon or being
published by Google.
But it looks, like apparently,
there's crossover and they can
be published by multiple
levels.
So how do you get the
content that you're
providing for e-readers?
PRATIP BANERJI: So the
Goodreads site--
The first part of your
question is, why does
Goodreads have so many
providers listed?
So, they're affiliates of
multiple reading services.
That's what it boils down to.
The second part of your
question, where do we get the
content that we sell?
We have relationships
with publishers.
OK.
So you're not looking
for individual--
I mean, things aren't coming
from individual authors, kind
of thing, as in a
publish-on-demand--
obviously this is
read-on-demand, if you will--
but it's all with established
large
publishers, is that right?
PRATIP BANERJI: We have over
5,000 publishers right now
that have made their
books available.
So big and small.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRATIP BANERJI: OK.
Great.
Well thank you very much, and
enjoy the rest of Google I/O.
KEVIN LANDRY: One more--
PRATIP BANERJI: Oh,
one more question?
Sorry.
Would you like to ask it?
Go ahead.
We still have three minutes.
[INAUDIBLE]
--kind of things covered?
PRATIP BANERJI: This particular
program is for eBooks.
But the Google Affiliate Network
offers programs for
all kinds of different
products.
OK, so we need some process
to register, right?
PRATIP BANERJI: Yep.
Yep.
And that'll all be documented
on a public
website when it launches.
KEVIN LANDRY: You can sign up
on the form to get more
information later.
And country's not open yet, and
the affiliate program's
not there yet?
PRATIP BANERJI: Right now US.
Right now in the US.
All right.
Cool.
Thanks.
PRATIP BANERJI: Great.
Thank you everybody.
KEVIN LANDRY: Thank you.